hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in the beginning of book nine of his
meditations Marcus Aurelius is going to
tell us and himself since he's writing
to himself a number of ways in which
people it's translated differently
commit blasphemy is one way of
translating it or sinning doing
something that is against the the god or
the god something that is impious asebe
in the Greek and this is a verb some of
the translations for example that if
Hayes will say Injustice is a kind of
blasphemy but literally what he's
actually saying is the one who does this
commits blasphemy or sins by doing so so
it's much more focused on the agency the
responsibility of the person who's going
wrong and he begins by saying that the
person who does wrong or commits
Injustice right the person who's in the
process of committing Injustice of
transgressing norms of violating
Promises of doing the things they
shouldn't do blasphemes or sins
and this is not simply
a unthinking equation of well you do
what God doesn't like therefore you're
committing Injustice or vice versa he's
going to provide us his readers with
some explanations
so the first one that he's going to say
is nature designed right uh Kata scale
aquias we're going against Nature's
intention or design or how it actually
like arranged things we're transgressing
that by doing wrong nature designed
rational beings for each other's
sakela right so on the account of each
other and and you know rational beings
logica right so those who possess reason
so by doing wrong we are transgressing
what nature intended for us to help not
to harm one another as they deserve and
he also talks about Nature's
willema right the decision the choice
the intention that nature has and now
here's where it gets very interesting
and there's theological Dimension to it
to transgress Nature's will is to
blaspheme or sin not just against God
but the oldest of the Gods
is he saying that nature is older than
all the other gods
well yes and no you know the stoics
thought that Zeus
god or Zeus is the capital G God but is
also the entirety of the universe which
is arranged according to reason a reason
that itself possesses and which is
providential so by going against what
our nature our distinctive rational
nature is we are transgressing against
nature we're blaspheming in that way and
then he goes on and he's going to give
us a whole bunch of other things that
also turn out to be blasphemy and he's
going to give us interesting
justifications for that so to lie or
literally the person who lies pseudo
menos the one who is engaging in sudos
in in lying also blasphemes why well
because it's in just right so there's
that part as well if lying is committing
Injustice well then the person who
commits Injustice also commits blasphemy
or sins but there's a more complex set
of ideas at play nature means the nature
of that which is and that which is and
that which is the case are closely
linked so that nature is synonymous with
truth Nature's connected with truth and
truth is the first cause proton haitia
of all true things so there's truth
alethea and then there's all the true
matters states of Affairs things that we
could say right so nature and Truth
intersects so he says to lie
deliberately hakon choosing to lie this
disrupts the harmony uh this this is
involves deception
exopatone right uh apatine is to to
deceive to trick to pull the wool over
somebody's eyes so deceiving well
deceiving is committing Injustice right
you're not supposed to deceive other
human beings and then if we're lying
involuntarily Akon the opposite of
haycon it disrupts the harmony
diaphone right of nature
um and so he says it disrupts its order
he's in conflict with the way the world
is structured the cosmos right the
arrangement of the totality and he says
as is as anyone is who deviates towards
what is opposed to the truth even
against his will and then he points out
one other really important thing as
human beings as the rational creatures
nature gave us resources capacities
criteria that we can develop for
distinguishing uh literally deciding
between right karenine false and true
and it's up to us to actually use those
and develop those resources
since the person has neglected them they
can't tell the difference but they're
still blaspheming or sinning by
committing the Injustice of disrupting
the harmony of the universe even if they
at this point in time can't tell the
difference between true and false
they're taking in for example by
misinformation or pseudoscience or
something like that so now we have two
things
lying is bad committing Injustice more
broadly bad both of them are against the
oldest God in the universe nature
then he goes on and he says to pursue
pleasure as a good to be a hedonist
right and to flee from pain as evil now
pain here is not Lupe the psychological
feeling of being in pain but rather
ponos which can mean pain but it can
also mean like trouble toil having to
put up with crap right having to plow
through things and so you know things
that are ponderos are not uh Hayden you
know they're not pleasure right so
um pursuing pleasure is a good fleeing
pain is an evil this is also to to sin
to to go wrong against the Divine why
would that be the case well as he's
going to go on and say
someone who does that is bound to find
themselves complaining about nature why
are they going to complain about nature
complaining it doesn't treat the good
and bad as they deserve but let the bad
enjoy pleasure and the things that
produce it and makes the good suffer
pain and the things that produce pain
the world doesn't seem to be fair well
the world doesn't seem to be fair if you
think that fairness has to do with
Pleasure and Pain maybe the world is
fair but that's the wrong way to measure
it but if we have this pleasure pain
motivated mindset where those are the
goods and bads we're going to fall into
this problematic perspective right so we
don't want to be complaining about
nature you know oh my knees hurt you
know when it snows oh the universe is
wrong because of that well that's that's
silly from a stoic perspective
he also tells us that if we do think
that pain is the is the bad and pleasure
is the good we are going to necessarily
do the wrong things right
to fear pain is to fear something that's
bound to happen the world being what it
is and it's interesting that he uses the
word phobicide to fear here rather than
just to
um you know uh flee Flu Game pain right
so now it's not just like avoidance now
it's worrying about pain it's fearing it
as something yet to come for us if we do
that then we are going to make some bad
decisions likewise if we think that
pleasure is the fundamental good he says
you're going to pursue it and you can
hardly avoid wrongdoing in doing so and
that is greatly
blasphemous that is greatly sinning
because you're you know doing a
generally a bunch of things that are
wrong you're probably going to lie cheat
and steal right you're gonna do things
that are wrong but you're also going to
screw yourself up in the process
then there's this interesting discussion
and we got to be a little bit careful
here in terminology so
there's a term here that's translated as
indifferent now that is a very important
stoic concept being indifferent to the
indifference things that don't have the
value of genuine good or Genuine evil
but are in between and may have some
limited value but not enough value to
raise them to that that is a translation
of
adiafori right or a diaphoria or Adie
foron or adiafora all these don't make a
difference
right not making a difference the term
that Marcus is using here that a lot of
the translations are rendering as
indifferent including hazes is a
different one
Epi says
a piece says is coming from the word
esos which means equal right so EP is on
and what we have here is that nature is
treating things equally right and
indifferent isn't bad as a translation
it's just a little bit uh of a trip up
if you're used to the stoic terminology
so he says some things nature is
indifferent to it doesn't you know take
a stand one way or another how do we
know this well if it privileged one over
the other it wouldn't have created both
of them if it thought that one was more
valuable ultimately than the other and
so there's a consequence that comes from
this if we want to follow the oiken
nature which again May major basic stoic
conception living in accordance with
nature following nature being in harmony
with nature if we want to do that to be
of one mind with it then we need to also
share in this indifference or literally
seeing things that we typically don't
view as equal as being equal being equal
in the most important respect
so what are these examples uh Pleasure
and Pain now you know in this listing in
the Greek
they use Pros for the first one and then
they just rattle off a whole bunch of
these uh connected things we could read
in there privileging one over the other
pleasure pain which do you want pleasure
is better to have than pain right well
from the perspective of Nature and the
perspective of the person who is
following nature neither pleasure nor
pain is actually better than the other
one they're just things that are and
they may have value in relation to say
the organism right pleasure maybe in
indicative of something going well as
far as the structure of the organism and
its organs Go Pain may be a sign of
something going wrong but nature dulls
up both of these right so
Pleasure and Pain
life and death Thanatos death bias life
and then Fame and anonymity doxa adoxia
right having doxa having reputation or
fame not having it right these are all
essentially
indifferent they don't make a difference
they are on the same level as far as
nature is concerned so we should be
looking at that as well then he says
well what does this actually mean
to say that nature is indifferent and
this is where it gets really interesting
so there's a term that's being used here
besides the Epi says right
um being equal treating them equally
this means to deal with or to use again
a very important technical term
nature
treats these things or acts in them
indifferently what does this mean well
this means that they happen
indifferently at different times to the
things that exist and the things that
come into being after them so things
that come into being things that come
into being later uh and and through some
he says ancient degree of Providence
so nature is just a bunch of processes
that are happening and but it is Guided
by some
rational plan a Providence paranoia in
Greek is the term that that's used here
right so there is an ordering to these
matters
um the decree by which from some initial
starting point it embarked on the
creation or the world that we know by
laying down the principles of what was
the common determining the generative
forces right so nature is this vast
complex causal Matrix which connects not
just space and things in space but time
as well and is arranged providentially
and in that providential ordering nature
hasn't given priority to pleasure over
pain life over death or fame over not
fame and you could say well wait a
second
every animal even plants have a desire
to continue their life or an Impulse
whatever we want to call it right you
can say well yes that nature gave these
to all these things but that doesn't
mean that life itself
is prioritized by Nature nor that pain
or pleasure is prioritized over pain so
we can look at it as rational creatures
as yeah those are nice things those you
know all things being equal okay I'll
try to you know have some pleasure and
avoid pain but I'm not going to Center
my existence around that because when I
do I screw up I wind up doing the wrong
things I'm out of whack with the rest of
the cosmos and with my fellow rational
creatures and with nature itself the
oldest of the Gods as we see him saying
here so this is a very interesting and
luminative passage about the theological
views of Marcus Aurelius we fit into a
cosmos that is ordered by the oldest of
the Gods and with which we ought to try
our best to conform and we've been given
the resources to do that by having
rational Minds